Hey, what's up everyone? We're going to
do something called flash blessing.
Flash blessing. You got that? Um, here
at
EPS and ETSs, uh, one of the big
Christian academic conferences of the
year, but it's also the best place to
get books
on Christian topics, theology, um,
anything involving apologetics. Um
because all the publishers come out,
they bring out all their latest stuff.
They cut out the middleman, so
everything is massively discounted.
Anyway, best place to get books for
people who read them. I know four guys
here who still read a ton of stuff and
yet never have book money to get all the
books they want. I was thinking we could
all help them out this year. you know,
two of them, Anthony Rogers and Vocab
Malone.
Um, Anthony, I've never seen anyone read
that much stuff and absorb it all. Uh,
Vocab, he gets uh he does tons of stuff.
He gets everything on the topics he's
interested in and goes out and use it
with the Hebrew Israelites and so on.
Anthony, everything dealing with the
Trinity, Tahed, and so on. Then there's
two guys you don't know
>> and you might never know them, but uh,
super cool guys. They are both seminary
students. One's from Pakistan. They call
him Taliban for Christ.
And the other is from Nigeria. They call
him Boo Haram for Christ. But these are
guys who are training, learning
apologetics, um learning palemics,
learning theology
to confront Islam effectively, where
they're from.
I'd like to uh basically cover all these
guys books, anything they want. So set
up a little give and go. Um, we put
$2,000 basically four guys that would
give them 500 bucks each. So anyway, if
everyone goes over there, chips in five
or 10 bucks, I can tell them tomorrow
that they've got a book budget and I
think they'll probably lose their minds.
So let's do the easy part. Let's kick in
a few bucks. These guys will get some
books, learn the material, and they'll
do the rest.
Links in the description box.